you want more hot bodies well you're
always gonna find them on The
Bachelorette but on Mondays episode on
ABC the guys have an opportunity to show
their funny side
unfortunately Amy Schumer can't seem to
find it
things got real weird tonight that's not
the only thing I can do with my yeah
there are a couple of moments I was like
I don't know if that's funny or if I
should be concerned they surprised us
really Amy and her crew are coaching a
group date where the guys are forced to
do stand-up for Kaitlyn and they are
stressed I sweat like Juan Pablo and the
women tell all
absolutely I mean I really tried to help
them but a lot of them ignored ignore
just straight-up ignored our advice yeah
turns out Amy is a big bachelorette fan
do you already have rules for yourself
like I'm not gonna kiss everybody I've
already kissed everybody I'm kind of
feeling like amy has a little girl crush
on Kaitlyn
I love Kaitlyn
and I want to spend the rest of my be
real with me
like we're sisters now look I'm
believing to like be real mad about it